I want to look at a clip now of a
radical republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene I'm being
interviewed by Alex Jones on Infowars
now as many of you know Alex Jones
recently attacked me thank your lucky
stars every day you're not Dave backman
right oh the bonus show where you want
to make money but everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad so
Alex Jones really doesn't like me but he
really likes Marjorie Taylor green and
that tells us a lot about Marjorie
Taylor green Marjorie Taylor Green in
one minute yesterday while being
interviewed by Alex Jones
um told so many lies that some are
likening this to a psychotic break
um this is a sitting member of Congress
guys this is this is someone who's
currently a member of Congress and the
funniest part is her starting by saying
everything going on with covet is mental
illness let's take a listen this is
truly mental illness now I know she said
mental illness she means mental illness
guys trust me wearing a asked today
after two years of this Chinese virus
that has infected our country this
man-made Chinese virus that Dr fauci
sent our tax dollars to and contributed
to but she can be I mean I mean
contributed mineral uh it's it's just
visibly struggling to speak people still
wearing masks I mean it's truly mentally
ill we know the masks don't work and the
vaccines don't work now both of those
statements are untrue masks do work
those lame Gators that people pull over
their face and cloth masks don't work
that well
if you've got two people wearing n95s I
mean this has been studied extensively
um if one person is infected and one
person's not and both are wearing n95s
the odds of transmission are very very
low if people aren't wearing masks the
odds of transmission go up uh you know
who knows how many times I don't want to
understate it but they go up
dramatically vaccines work new data
suggests that you are 97 times more
likely to die of covid right now
if you have no vaccines versus if you
have three doses so what what she's
saying is not true it's not even close
to true people that are vaccinated are
still getting covered now of course
that's true but it ignores the reality
that if you're unvaccinated you're 97
times more likely to you know it's
exhausting at this point guys but I
think that people really have blood on
their hands that have stopped the the
prescriptions of ivermectin refuse
people who have had sick family members
in the hospital of not being able to
take Ivermectin now remember Ivermectin
has not been demonstrated to be
effective against covid I would love it
if Ivermectin zpax
hydroxychloroquine zinc whatever I would
love it if that was effective for covid
these are cheap ubiquitous things I have
no ideological opposition
but they've not been demonstrated to
work against covet
treatment are there
deaths that are reported on the ver
system and hold people accountable now
the vares system is another darling of
the American right remember anybody can
report anything they want to the very
system well but David that would be
against the law
uh people could get in trouble for that
is anybody getting in trouble for the
false reports no so anybody can report
anything to the Vare system and even
honest reports to the vayer system about
people who died six weeks after getting
a vaccine when you have hundreds of
millions of people getting vaccinated
including elderly folks and sick folks
of course some of them are going to die
within six weeks of getting the vaccine
and they would have died within six
weeks anyway and it can have nothing to
do with covet even never mind the
vaccine so she's wrong about everything
she's you know Alex Berenson is sort of
the the most the wrongest man on the
pandemic
uh Marjorie Taylor green is sort of like
the wrongest woman on the pandemic
but the people died well I think they're
guilty of murder right not giving
Ivermectin makes you guilty of murder
and by the way why do all these right
Wingers instead of saying Dr fauci they
say Dr falchi I I just why can't they
just pronounce things the way they are
uh so Marjorie Taylor green
dangerously unhinged and the remember
the messages
member of Congress one of 435 and almost
certain to be re-elected to her seat in
Georgia
one of our sponsors is established
titles if you're looking for a perfect
last minute Valentine's Day gift check
this out it's funny it's Unique and
they're supporting a great cause
established titles is a Project based on
the historic Scottish custom where
landowners are called Lords and Ladies
and so established titles lets you
ceremonially buy as little as one square
foot of dedicated land in aberdeenshire
Scotland so that you can call yourself a
lord or lady you get an official
certificate with a Crest they let you
see exactly where your spot is located
but in return for each one sold
established titles will plant a tree to
protect the beautiful pristine Woodlands
of Scotland established titles also
supports Global Charities like one tree
planted and trees for the future so it's
a fun gift but you're also helping to
support something great and right now
they're having a huge Valentine's Day
sale on top of that you'll get an extra
10 percent off when you go to
establishtitles.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman the link is down below